ya van tres primeros ministros de Reino
Unido que dejan el cargo en seis años
Dave Cameron Teresa May y ahora Boris
Johnson cómo queda el partido
conservador
Hola buenas tardes Muchas gracias por la
invitación cómo queda el partido
conservador Más allá de que como bien
acabas de mencionar en los últimos seis
años han pasado tres primeros ministros
ahora contando cuando Boris Johnson
finalmente deje el cargo el partido
conservador no obstante viene de haber
ganado unas elecciones generales en
diciembre 2019 en las cuales ha
aumentado su mayoría Por lo cual no no
viene
muy golpeado va a venir golpeado por por
esta salida de Boris pero pero va a
seguir siendo el partido en el poder y
iba a seguir siendo muy probablemente el
partido en el poder por varios años más
en el Reino Unido ahora lo que queda es
la carrera por quién será el o la
sucesora el sucesor o la sucesora de
bori Johnson en los próximos meses
ella ya anunció que que no va a
renunciar hasta que que se nombre un
sucesor una sucesora definitiva Así que
no no sería de extraño que tengamos un
par de meses más por lo menos hasta
hasta el fin del verano hasta septiembre
cuando haya un nuevo líder al partido
conservador y Por ende un nuevo un nuevo
Primer Ministro primera ministro en el
Reino Unido pero pero el partido
conservador si bien se ve algo
debilitado por por esta serie de líderes
que
duran Algunos años en el cargo no no no
largos mandatos como anteriormente sigue
siendo el partido de gobierno hace más
de 12 años está en el gobierno y y va a
seguir siendo el partido el partido en
el poder claro y es que ya han salido a
destacar por ejemplo una serie de
nombres varios del gabinete de Johnson
Pero por qué no hay una imagen fuerte
dentro del partido que se perfile para
reemplazar al Premier
Es una muy buena pregunta porque no
solamente ha sido golpeado por
escándalos o tanto de corrupción como de
no cumplir las reglas que ellos mismos
habían impuesto durante la larga
cuarentena por el covid 19 por un lado
bueno el llamado Party Gates las cuales
ya perdí la cuenta eran más de 17 y
estas clandestinas que que camufladas
como ven todos de trabajo tuvieron lugar
durante Durante los momentos más
estrictos del lockdown o de la
cuarentena en el Reino Unido pero sumado
eso también escándalos de corrupción por
ejemplo
hasta hace pocos días el ministro de
finanzas ahora del ministro finanzas
Reyes unac te decía se ha visto envuelto
en un cierto escándalo Por así decirlo
por
no no tanto de su parte pero sí por
empresas de la mujer que no estaban
declaradas por lo tanto es uno de los
favoritos también para para suceder a
Boris pero pero la falta también de un
liderazgo claro al momento tiene que ver
con que no
son el único implicado en escándalos o
en polémicas en los últimos meses sobre
todo sino que salpica varios pesos
pesados del partido conservador también
sin embargo hay algunos nombres como te
mencioné esta barriga es una pero
también se menciona por ejemplo la
actual Secretario de Defensa
vengo a los es uno de los favoritos
según las las casas de apuestas por por
suceder a Boris en el cargo también se
hablaba de listas que es la actual
ministra de relaciones exteriores por
algunos nombres